it looks like mist but is actually smoke
smoke from forest fires that have
ravaged jungles in Indonesia and
Malaysia and that's prompted a dispute
between the two neighboring nations over
who is to blame for this blanket of
toxic haze thousands of firefighters are
trying to douse the flames that have
pushed air quality in the region to
unhealthy levels this is not a
Children's Hospital it's a classroom but
this is the last lesson for the day
concerned staff worried it's too
dangerous for the kids to remain here
the air they're breathing has become
toxic several thousand other schools
have also closed down here into real
province where the air pollution index
has hit the hazardous level residents
have been flocking to hospitals citing
respiratory problems
[Music]
the doctor said he experienced shortness
of breath due to the smog he also has a
fever and a cough so basically it's
caused by the fumes after treatment
breathing easy again but doctors say
there are many similar cases in our
intensive care unit facility the average
number of patients with respiratory
problems has increased by about 25 to 30
patients a day their suffering is
connected to forest fires raging for
over a month Indonesia has deployed 9000
personnel to combat the flames which
were seen across the Sumatra and Borneo
islands and also in neighboring Malaysia
Indonesian authorities say satellites
have detected 3600 fires in the region
such places are often set deliberately
to clear land for planting and shared
borders means shared air in Malaysia the
drifting smoke has enveloped Kuala
Lumpur's skyline irritating the Capitals
residents
the view of the smoke is not good to
look at it's a bit difficult to breathe
because the air is so dirty Malaysia
says it remains concerned about the
persistent transboundary haze and has
offered Indonesia help to extinguish two
places but Indonesia says it's not alone
and accuses malaysia of not being
transparent about its fires but
whoever's to blame both nations are
bracing for more days of noxious air